rappelez vous à devoir le 25 hier
commentateurs
at de la défunte chaîne ctv qui a si
souvent défrayé les manchettes pour ses
propos parfois injurieux
il a lancé un nouveau site d'information
internet de red bull est la première
ministre de l'alberta riccio notre lit a
voulu refuser l'accès à un petit point
presse à l'une des journalistes de red
bull sous prétexte qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une vraie source journalistique
vivement la liberté de presse et la
levée de boucliers qui a suivi ça
prenait bien finalement une première
ministre de gauche pour inciter toute la
classe journalistique à se porter à la
défense du commentateur de droite que
tout le monde aime détester pour tous le
contrôle qu'il a tenté d'exercer sur les
médias lorsqu'ils étaient au pouvoir
stephen harper avait bien compris qu'il
valait mieux ne pas se mêler de la
définition de qui est ou n'est pas un
journaliste on ne peut pas à la fois
vanté l'importance de la diversité des
voix et tenter de faire taire celle qui
nous déplaisent voilà c'est ce qui
conclut cette édition des coulisses du
pouvoir vous remercie d'avoir été des
nôtres et à la semaine prochaine